we've got a pair out here which arrives
this morning called by Brook and keenel
so they're one of our regular pairs at
slimbridge nature reserving
gloucestershire the Buick swans are back
from their summer in Siberia but each
year there are fewer the European
population has slumped by a third in two
decades the wetlands are being drained
for things like agriculture for other
land use so there's lots and lots of
pressures where people are wanting to
use that available space but wetlands
are some of the most biodiverse habitats
on Earth they can hold lots and lots of
wildlife not just our Buick swans but
also suspicious all over the world
across the planet the abundance and
variety of life is in free fall one
million species are threatened with
Extinction and the United Nations is
holding the nature equivalent of the
recent cop 27 climate Summit in the hope
of thrashing out a global blueprint to
reverse the decline
this isn't just about the loss of a few
cute animals they are a symptom of an
underlying crisis in natural habitats
that are sick and shrinking and we
depend on them too for our life support
the summit called cop15 will seek Global
agreement to reverse the loss of nature
by 2030 conservation groups want an end
to agricultural subsidies that encourage
deforestation and a reduction in the use
of pesticides to reverse the crash in
insect numbers we are losing our
pollinators and our ability to grow
crops we know that we are destroying our
forests and our ability to draw down
carbon if we want a stable and secure
Society if we want to tackle all the
crises the climate the food security
crisis we have to put nature at the
heart of our decision making Britain is
one of the most nature-depleted
countries on the planet
uncertainty of the government's
commitment to environmental regulations
hasn't built confidence that ministers
care but one Insider a former green
campaigner insists things are changing
there are lots of really good things
happening lots of policies still to come
through this is now the moment when we
have to start getting serious it's all
very well to have these targets and to
have the policies if they don't make a
difference on the ground then there's
every good reason to ask questions this
Summit will determine the health of
nature for centuries to come but
conservationists warn time is running
out right now the planet is experiencing
the largest loss of life since the
dinosaurs
Thomas More Sky News in gloucestershire